today I'm going to be talking about
whether or not you should create your
own data Science Library so quickly by
way of introduction my name is Pierre
Ferrante I am the principal data
scientist at Aetna Aetna was recently
acquired by CBS so we say Aetna a CVS
health company now I also advise a
healthcare startup called plate health
on algorithms and data strategy my
background from an academic standpoint
was in quantitative finance and
predictive analytics applied machine
learning spent about 10 years hopping
around different industries but the
majority of my time has been in
healthcare really really great field for
individuals that are strong in tech and
want to solve really big heart problems
because healthcare is is wrought with
them and I do some teaching on the side
I have an invention which I'm proud of
and I used to organize a big data
science meetup in in Kansas City
something that I tell people about
myself and then they're like oh that's
interesting that was like the most
interesting thing he told me was I take
apart mechanical watches and I put them
back together so some people find that
cool I don't know it's just something
I've always done I like to understand
how things work so enough about me I
want to know a little bit about you all
who in this room by show of hands writes
the code all right a lot of people write
the code great who is classically
trained as a computer scientist show
offense all right so maybe about one
third of the room there and who here has
contributed to an open-source project
all right
the numbers are getting smaller and
smaller but they're a handful of you
thank you very much and who here has
authored their own library brand-new
project all right one two three people
all right cool congratulations so maybe
some of this will be familiar to you
maybe you went through some of these
same thoughts along that journey so
before I get into it I just want to say
a little bit about Aetna so we're
we're a large health insurance company
right our business we're in the business
of keeping our members as healthy as
possible the healthier our members are
the better it is for us right
when CVS acquired us CVS in long story
short they're taking a very long
position on health you might remember
that CVS stopped selling cigarettes in
their stores while back a huge revenue
hit but they're all in as a health care
company a health and wellness company so
what my team and my department focus on
are creating better health-related
outcomes through we build a catalog of
different actions so it may be something
very innocuous like hey have you taken
your 10,000 steps today but on the other
end of the spectrum it might be more
clinically involved perhaps you suffer
from a chronic respiratory disease and
you haven't seen your pulmonary
specialist in the last several months
and by the way you forgot to pick up
your inhaler at the pharmacy last week
so we'll try to engage these members
over a host of different channels with
different behavioral economic principles
in our messaging so that we can
encourage behavior change for those
members and we do this at scale so I
think Aetna last time I checked about
twenty four million members so when
we're running these large controlled
experiments were really doing it at a
massive scale all right does anybody
know francois this this gentleman works
at google contributes to tensorflow and
he tweets really intelligent things I
like this tweet from the other day and I
sort of worked it into to my talk but
the piece that I was interested in is is
the first bit a way to describe
intelligence is that it is the power to
produce abstraction so I'll be focusing
on abstraction a little bit in this talk
and it's it's really difficult to create
abstractions because you have to have a
great appreciation and understanding for
the lower-level intricacies to create
that abstraction that's why things is is
generally difficult because you have to
understand all of those things
and then regurgitate it in a very
approachable way which which takes a bit
of effort and we're all about
abstractions so if you go back in
history you know on the left you have
the abacus simple adding and subtracting
machine in the middle there you see
Charles Babbage's analytical machine
which was actually an incomplete work he
never never quite got it got it finished
but it was an abstraction on you know
lower level more tedious types of
computation and then on the far on the
far right you see an early computer so
why are we interested in abstraction so
I don't know about you but every day I
have 24 hours right I don't have enough
time the older I get the less time I
have and abstractions can afford us
greater productivity which is important
day-to-day as a data scientist
especially when we're doing a lot of
monotonous and redundant tasks like
cleaning data you know introspecting are
models so when we have the ability to
leverage an abstraction it's in our best
interest because then we'll be more
productive and generally speaking you
know as you as you become more abstract
you can achieve greater productivity so
some sample or some examples involving
different levels of abstraction machine
code right that's the most basic level
dealing with binary and then you have
assembly language has anybody here ever
written an assembly language any of the
CS grads in the room all right handful
of you did you enjoy doing that
do you reflect fondly on those days of
writing assembly language you kind of
liked it I can tell in the front row and
then you have lower-level languages like
see sometimes I ask a silly question
during interviews what's your desert
island programming language and most of
the time I'll get the answer like Python
or something but every now and then you
get somebody who who mentions C or C++
just because you can do anything under
the Sun essentially if you understand
those languages inside and out which I
appreciate and then you have
higher-level languages like Python that
create opportunities for people that
don't want to spend their time writing
assembly language or don't have the
wherewithal to learn the ins and outs of
C but they're still capable developers
capable creators and Python creates an
approachable higher-level language that
you can look at and read and it kind of
makes sense right that's that's pretty
cool as I was doing research into
different higher-level languages I came
across you know some obscure ones like
Moo and there's another language which
apparently is just an amalgamation of
Arnold Schwarzenegger movie quotes and
it's like a standalone high-level
language so if you don't have anything
to do this weekend I would explore that
and then on top of Python of course you
have libraries libraries that we
celebrate and use every day like numpy
and pandas and psych it right why does
everybody love psych it so much because
it has such a clean API it makes it
makes looking at a machine learning
pipeline very easy to understand this
happened this happened and then this
happened and then I can inverse
transform all of my great feature
transformations and I can call a fit
method and it's very approachable and
standardized and it gives way to greater
productivity so what I'll be talking
about today is a library that we
developed in-house called PI connect
it's not applicable to individuals
outside of the four walls of CVS and
Aetna and that's perfectly okay I'll
walk you through
why it was worth going through that
exercise for us
I've spoken with you know several
individuals over the past couple days or
over today and yesterday about different
projects that they developed in-house
that just makes sense for that business
and it's become a core part of that
business and that was really the
inspiration for 4pi connect for for me
and the co-author who will mention in a
bit here so I have to you know make a
joke about recreating the wheel here
because it's it's worth asking that
question of yourself it's you don't want
to just write some code for the sake of
writing code well sometimes you do
that's fair enough sometimes you want to
do that but you know I'm getting paid to
do what I do and I don't want to waste
people's time I don't want to waste my
company's money so it was it was a
prudent exercise for me to think about
did we really need this am i just
recreating the wheel is this something
that you know will will continue to help
others be more productive and generate
value so you have to ask yourself this
very basic question do you feel the pain
is there enough pain that warrants the
time and effort that goes into
developing a library like this I'll talk
you through a couple of our pain points
so our data science organization is
growing a lot it's 3 X in the year and a
half since I've been there and we're
bringing in talent at all different
levels so some folks just coming out of
grad school some folks coming out of
undergrad and some seasoned
professionals that have been developing
software for you know over a decade and
different individuals have different
needs have different proficiencies so
for some of those individuals that were
less seasoned we needed a way to get
them productive sooner rather than later
and I didn't want them bumbling around
you know with with a cond install for
the very first time do I pick install do
i canta install you know which version
do I use wanted to get through some of
those details or kind of abstract away
some of those details
another another problem that we had that
we were facing was that our cluster our
Hadoop cluster was running on an older
distribution Hortonworks actually and
you know some things are in your control
if I'm you know a root admin I can go
ahead and you know pull out all the
plumbing and I can change things but
when you have you know 50 60 peda bytes
of member information across 100 million
lives over several decades spread out on
that cluster you can't just pull out
wires like that right and there are
reasons defendable reasons why it may
have taken a longer time than I would
have preferred to update that
distribution but I had to figure out a
clever way to work around some of that
because as you know you know 2/7 won't
be supported for much longer a lot of
libraries have already formally
announced that they're no longer
supporting older versions and I want the
data scientists on my team to use new
libraries that leverage higher levels of
abstraction to accomplish more and
introduce new features so that was
another problem that we were trying to
overcome we also have a bunch of
different databases like you name it and
we probably have it somewhere
anything from mssql to you know Netezza
to you know all the data spread out on
our cluster to a db2 warehouse it's it's
all over the place and some of these
different databases require different
means of connecting and extracting that
data so that was something that we
needed to solve for as well
who here has messed around with spark or
hive configurations at one point or
another all right there are a fair
amount of you and there are a lot of
different you know parameters that you
can set with your with your spark in
your hive configuration that have a
material impact on the way that your job
is going to run so how do you kind of
instantiate a best practice you know
from from the get-go for a data
scientist that's it's the first time
working on a Hadoop cluster and
submitting a hive query
you can you can work around some of
those things by creating by creating
clever defaults that are sort of hidden
hidden away multiple installation
directories and jars all over the
cluster you know which is the latest
installation of this or that you know
very messy and we needed a way to point
to the right resource for for the right
job and lastly you know the last two
things here
users can sub-optimally persist data so
there are so many different ways that I
can create a high of table you know I
can write a big wide CSV out to my local
home directory and then I can move it
over to HDFS and then I can issue a high
of command to go ahead and create that
table but there's so much waste in what
I just told you like why is CSV why did
you put it in your home directory when
you created that table were you using
compression were you being smart about
partitioning opportunities when creating
that table things that you may not think
about the first time around but when
you're not really paying attention to
those things over time it can really add
up so we wanted to again abstract some
of that away so we created this project
called PI Connect which to my to my
dismay was actually already out there on
PI PI somewhere so sorry whoever
initially created PI connect and the way
that the way that I described PI connect
here it's a package designed
specifically for data scientists
analysts and engineers at Aetna very
very specific about that it aims to make
you more productive faster by
abstracting way cumbersome installation
and setup details like creating your
cond environment pointing locating
certain end points setting global
variables and things of that nature
and if you're interested this is my co
developer being way and I'm sure he
won't be happy about me using his
picture on the slide either he's a great
guy all right so let's talk a little bit
about PI connect
you can go ahead and clone it from the
Aetna Aetna repo enterprise repo if
you're working at Aetna of course and
then there's a command line installation
so what were some of the key motivations
and objectives for what I was trying to
do here I've mentioned a few times that
we wanted to accelerate user
productivity of course in the interest
of leveraging abstractions we wanted to
hide needless complexity with the
example that I mentioned a minute ago
about writing out a hive table we want
to promote you know some standardization
to reduce inefficiencies the the fourth
point is an interesting one and I'm sure
for those of you that have developed
your own libraries at one point or
another it will probably resonate with
you have to you introduce opinionated
best practices may be best practices
isn't the right word but when you're
writing software you're expressing your
opinion about what you think is the
right way to do something and of course
you can always poke holes in it and you
know challenge whether or not it's
universally applicable to every problem
Under the Sun and it may not be right
but that's that's part of doing it you
have to kind of draw a line in the sand
if you try to be everything to everyone
you know your scope will get out of
control and then you won't effectively
do what you set out to do in the first
place so there are some opinions that
get baked into into these types of
projects which kind of works into the
fifth point about 8020 most of the use
cases I wasn't trying to solve for
everybody I know some people will you
know send me an email and say oh why
doesn't do this or raise an issue oh
okay we'll consider that as a feature in
the future but wanted to solve 80% of
the use cases well and not 100 percent
of the use use cases not so well and
again some of the constraints that we
were trying to overcome individuals with
varying levels of proficiency everyone
can't be an admin nor would I ever
suggest that they try to be all the
different databases and multiple
software and compatibility issues
all right so who's my target site target
audience here I mentioned data
scientists and and the business analysts
and data engineers and consultants but
not the hardcore programmers I'm the
type of person that will look go into
the code and try to understand how
everything's working and some things
they may want to configure a different
way for example like your spark
configuration you know sometimes you
need a lot more resources and sometimes
you don't so you know you need to
occasionally go underneath the hood and
and mess around with some things and and
again this wasn't for hardcore
programmers the hardcore programmers
will know how to install those libraries
on their own and do some of the things
that the library sets out to accomplish
for for others so for those of you that
are developing software for others or
managing a team of data scientists or
analysts or engineers you want to
position your team to be successful you
don't want to just send them out into
the cold world and say hey good luck you
don't want to send them up a river with
a blindfold on right you want to
position them to be successful and give
them the tools that they need to be
successful you also want to position
them to be productive I'm going to harp
on that point quite a bit does anybody
know what this is what was that spark
err yeah this is a beastly spark err who
here likes troubleshooting spark errors
nobody right it is awful because it's an
abstraction wrapped in an abstraction
wrapped in an abstraction you're
probably using PI spark and it's really
difficult to understand exactly what
went wrong on the JVM so you know we
tried to avoid that situation so what
were some of the core features that that
we wanted to build into into this
library first off we wanted to get the
stalls right you know get a data
scientist starts I want them you know
writing some code exploring our data
within the first week so it manages the
condo build it it goes ahead and it sets
up Jupiter for them privacy and security
are of the utmost concern in in health
care especially so passwords and things
like that need to be encrypted and
decrypted when we're doing
authentication etc we also wanted to
avoid having them hunt and peck for the
right end points the right jars all over
all over the edge nodes or the cluster
so we were able to you know set up some
of those global variables that are that
are used to either build connection
strings or or establish a connection for
them beforehand and we also introduced a
set of standardized aliases which is
good because then everybody's talking
the same language who here has ever like
compared their bash RC with a co-worker
right it's like everybody always has
their own crazy aliases in there and
when you're trying to troubleshoot
something for someone sometimes you have
to go back and like undo the ball of
rubber bands and like hair and and
bubblegum and it's just it's awful so we
wanted to like get away from some of
that and and standardize some of those
things then for querying data this is
like the the biggest thing for me as a
data scientist it needs to be really
really simple to get at the data if you
can't get at the data it's our currency
right the more hop the more difficult
you make it for a data scientist to
access the data the lower your return on
investment is going to be for your whole
team and whatever you're working on so
we wanted to expose a really really
simple API for querying those multiple
backends we also wanted to afford users
the ability to submit asynchronous
queries where applicable standardized
column names has anybody ever had like
that that DBA or or whatever that that
created you know creates some column
names with like lower case than upper
case sometimes they'll use a space
sometimes they use an underscore
and then you're looking at your features
and your model and it's just it's all
over the place
so there's a bit of column
standardization next one is big
especially if you work on for us our
analytical sandbox are these edge nodes
that that are connected to our cluster
which have a lot of CPU and a lot of RAM
but if everybody is holding these
massive data frames in RAM you're going
to have some trouble at some point so by
doing some intelligent down casting
behind the scenes like converting
strings to categoricals by doing like
some basic inference about how many
unique values show up in a given column
and converting you know large numeric
types to smaller numeric types where
applicable you're able to drastically
reduce that memory footprint and the
user never even knew that happened right
they didn't know that I just downcast
their string to a categorical but we're
all the better for it and the last piece
which is sort of a work in progress as a
feature builder API so you know in
healthcare we're pulling in data points
about your prior medical utilization
your consumer patterns your social
determinants of health demography
pharmacy information retail information
you name it so when you're building a
model instead of hunting and pecking
again for hundreds and hundreds of
different variables wouldn't it be nice
to just say you know here are the unique
identifiers that I want to pull back
these attributes or features for within
a time span and give me back pharmacy
data demography and medical utilization
and then it will kind of auto build
those queries behind the scenes so
that's another piece that we're working
in persisting data I mentioned that
before instead of doing all those
different hops and then creating an
uncompressed unpartitioned table we can
just write a parquet file directly out
to HDFS and then do some smart DDL to
create that table so we're producing a
lot of overhead by by doing that
efficient distributed computing so how
do we get past this whole two-seven
limitation while using you know Python 3
plus environment there's a library
called sky which will essentially take a
tarball
of your cond environment working on an
edge node and ship it over to your your
cluster so then we can run we can run
spark jobs with latest and greatest PI
spark which is using Python 3 plus
without being limited to the Python q7
that's on the cluster so it was a clever
way to kind of work around the
distribution on that cluster while
affording our users the ability to use
more modern libraries I also mentioned
the spark and high of default
configurations before so that that
avoids you know data scientists from
using too many resources when they don't
actually need them and other niceties
boilerplate code and some simplified
imports because nobody likes a cluttered
namespace so since we are at PI data of
course it's worth calling out some of
the libraries that made all this
possible some of the abstractions that
we're leveraging to build our
abstraction numpy pandas PI spark
Jupiter PI hive h2o PI sparkling desk
sequel alchemy PI sequel and IBM D
because anybody used that one any db2
users out there ok I don't think so
so what does some of the code actually
look like you can see on the left-hand
side I mentioned we were trying to build
a really simple querying API that's
back-end agnostic so you know user would
just import pandas as PD PI connect
utils PU write some sequel and then they
can say query DB passing their sequel
specify the back-end and whether or not
they would like a data frame back
because sometimes you're just issuing
like DDL or something like that so
pretty simple but behind that there's a
lot of stuff right I mentioned the the
spark configuration I mentioned the hive
configuration the ability to talk to
different backends the intelligent down
casting all that stuff behind the scenes
and my end user doesn't need to know
about it unless they want to so this
quote here simplicity is are enormous ly
complex I Richard Oh more I'm actually
using a little out of context does
anybody know who Richard Moore is he's a
poet and this was about love so I'm sure
he didn't intend me to use it in
reference to like API development but I
thought it was applicable so what you
see on the surface three simple
arguments what's hidden beneath the
surface a bunch of needless complexity
for 80% of my users which version of
Python am I using do I need to worry
about spark compatibility how should it
be configured what's my connection
string look like can I use good ol siku
alchemy or do I have to use IBM DB a
bunch of important stuff but not so
important to the end user another
example for writing to hive you can see
again just write to hive pass in the
data frame specify a table and then two
simple operations create or append of
course life is more complex than create
and append but most of the users again
80/20 that's what they're doing one of
the creating a table and mentioned
before you know compression partitioning
opportunities those are things that you
look for in an optimal world but when
you're appending who here has ever done
in a penned or tried to do in a penned
using spark and then you get an error
because your data doesn't line up with
the data that you're trying to append to
it happens was happening quite a bit for
some of our users so one of the the neat
little things that we worked in was just
doing some schema inference so quickly
paying the table the target table that
you're trying to append to take note of
the schema and then run a quick schema
transform on the data that you are about
to append to that table again the user
doesn't know that it's happening they
don't realize that I had a float but I'm
trying to append to a table with an int
but it just works so there is there's a
downside to abstractions of course it
can't all be you know golden confetti
here so when you when you do climb that
complexity ladder or that abstraction
ladder rather you give away a little bit
of control right you that the low-level
extensibility that you have in a sea you
know you don't always have in a Python
which sometimes is good sometimes it's
bad but as long as you're transparent
about that that exchange upfront and you
acknowledge what some of the trade-offs
are you know you're well positioned and
the really really good software doesn't
necessarily always have to make that
compromise so you know in earlier
versions with like PI torch versus
tensorflow
you know the first version a lot of
users like PI torch because you could go
in there and you could change things
around a little bit more you can
introspect your models so there are ways
to to have your cake and eat it too but
it takes more time effort and foresight
all right so is all this stuff worth
worth the time and effort I'd say so
based on some really oversimplified
calculations here like on the left hand
side taking into account what the value
per minute of our data scientists are
based on like a mean salary how much
time we're saving them with the initial
startup costs so avoiding that cold
start by handling somebody's doing the
math right now right
installing a speed handling the
installation getting them going the
daily speed up in minutes by not having
to write some of these functions from
the ground up and being able to use
boilerplate or high-level abstractions
counting for you know approximately year
in workdays with a really low ball
estimation of the number of users
because I think we're at about twice
that for the PI connect users in-house
and then just a discount factor of 50%
because I'm a nice guy
and we can see you know non-trivial
annual savings for the effort which is
which is nice you want to make sure that
that it's all worth the effort in the
end so should you develop your own
library I would consider these four
questions is there a legitimate need
right that's the that's the first
question do you feel that pain is that
does that pain exist does something
already exist that you could potentially
leverage you don't want to reinvent the
wheel just for the sake of reinventing
the wheel unless you're intentionally
trying to learn something new and do you
have expertise or willingness to see it
through just creating V 1.1 putting it
out there without any supporting
documentation and then you don't answer
any of the emails or look at any of the
issues that's not really the responsible
way of going about it so you need to
have a little bit of wherewithal to to
see these types of projects through and
lastly is the juice worth the squeeze
are you creating value for your users or
your organization or or whoever here so
really that's it for me and if you have
any questions be glad to take them
[Applause]
yeah you can just raise your hand
it's a good question so as far as like
buying is concerned if I have a really
good widget I don't want to force it
upon you I want you to want to use that
widget and a lot of the the inspiration
for creating the library in the first
place
came back to paint common pain points so
you know when when one user started
using it and then it things worked and
another user starts using it and
eventually that user base grows I am
afforded a little bit of my my time to
solve problems like this and and kind of
create scalable solutions within my
organization so at the beginning it was
kind of off the side of the desk but
once I had a version out there that
people were using and you're measuring
the value and you can quantify you know
the value that you're creating for the
organization and you know how you're
incrementally making each data
scientists just a little bit more
productive than it really warrants
setting setting aside some some hard
time to continue the development yep
yeah that's a good question
so typically either Bing way or I will
you know make the change we're
constantly looking at any issues that
may arise or fielding emails from from
our users but don't want to put up walls
I want to encourage everybody in the
organization to take ownership of
something like this so anybody can put
in a pull request if they have a feature
that they want to add given that our
culture is not necessarily one of
software developers from day one I would
never stand in somebody's way who wants
to contribute to a project like that and
prohibit their growth so maybe that
changes at a certain state of maturity
but it'll be a happy day when there are
so many people that are issuing pull
requests that I have to say no all right
well thank you very open other--
question
I hadn't thought about that but if there
are aspects of what we've developed that
are interesting and useful to people
outside of our organization then I would
be glad to open-source any of it you
know with the one thing that comes to
mind you know the high level API for
querying a bunch of different backends
but then there's a lot of maintenance
that needs to be done when one of those
under underlying libraries changes their
API or introduces some new functionality
so I could see that becoming like you
know a large time commitment but you
know if if there's good reason to I
would love to open-source any any bit of
it all right well thank you all very
much